today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video so I
want to be really careful about this
segment what I want to do is I want to
steal man or make the strongest possible
left-wing argument against broad
lockdowns and stay at home orders as a
way to deal with coronavirus and I want
to be really clear there are lots of
really bad arguments on the right
against lockdowns what would a left-wing
case against lockdowns look like that's
what I want to answer today so as a
reminder bad arguments against lockdowns
from the right include things like only
old people will die and we don't really
need to worry about that that's a bad
argument against lockdowns
stay at home orders or government
tearing tyranny or like nazis or
whatever no that's wrong and that is a
bad argument against lockdowns the left
wants people to be unemployed no that's
a very bad argument against lockdowns
stay at home orders don't save anyone no
that's a bad argument against lockdowns
the economy is simply more important
than people's lives or we should be
willing to sacrifice grandma or
lockdowns are merely meant to hurt
donald trump's reelection chances these
are all terrible arguments against
lockdowns and stay at home home orders I
think you get it there are lots of
really bad right-wing arguments against
stay-at-home orders let me present maybe
a more realistic left-wing case against
the full lockdowns that some places have
been doing so on the Left we recognize
as a guiding principle essentially that
in American society and an American in
the American economy it is the working
class the working poor the lower-middle
class blue-collar workers it's all these
groups who are more vulnerable who are
more precariously sitting on the edge
between being able to pay for their
living expenses and not and they are the
first to get the shaft from our economic
system for lack of a better term and at
the same time it is those exact people
who are most hurt by broad stay-at-home
orders
it's not really the white-collar workers
it's not the lawyers it's not the people
who can work from home it's not brand
managers and management consultants the
people most hurt by stay-at-home orders
are restaurant workers grocery store
employees agricultural agricultural
workers delivery drivers people in
transportation uber and lyft etc etc etc
these are folks who have less power to
begin with in our economy they have less
of a financial cushion to get through a
calamity and who either lose their jobs
or have to work in dangerous conditions
or see their hours reduced without extra
pay thanks to the stay at home orders so
if we think about who is most hurt by a
broad lockdown it's the very people that
we on the Left have prioritized as it
should be because they are the most
taken advantage of now at the same time
even though we've had broad stay at home
orders in many places we've completely
failed to actually protect the people
most at risk older folks people in
nursing homes long-term care facilities
here in Massachusetts at one point half
of all deaths were in nursing homes the
average age of death here in
Massachusetts as of yesterday is 82
years of age I don't I I think I assume
that's median I'm not sure how it's been
calculated but it's been widely reported
by health authorities 82 is the average
age of death we have failed to protect
nursing homes and this is happening
nationally there are some states I told
you yesterday the day before even hiding
nursing home deaths which over under
states the problem even more we've not
done enough testing which from day one
would have been a fantastic way to
identify more cases quickly isolate
people we didn't invest in fever clinics
which is a colloquial term basically
places for people who have the disease
but are not super sick that they need to
be in a hospital places to isolate like
South Korea has done while they recover
so if you want to make a left wing case
against broad lockdowns the argument
would be we could have skipped such a
broad lockdown we could have stayed much
more open in terms of restaurants and
some other places certainly large
sporting events concerts had to be
canceled but we
could have kept more stuff open could
have kept it open with mandatory masks
we could have much earlier spent way
more money on safeguarding older folks
long term care and nursing home
facilities and way more money should
have been spent early on testing from
the beginning so this is not so much
about blame I mean you know there's
blame to go around the federal
government has a huge amount of blame
state governments have failed in many
cases to protect older populations this
particular segment is not about blame we
know there's plenty to go around
but there are things that could have
been done now I want to be really clear
I'm not falling for this entire children
and young people aren't affected by the
virus we are seeing children affected to
some degree some with a Kawasaki like
illness we are seeing you know younger
adults to some degree affected but the
mortality rate for people under 65
particularly those without pre-existing
conditions or comorbidities is
infinitesimally small and you know we
hear about healthy 42 year old died of
coronavirus yeah but understand that
those numbers are close to zero and this
is not like the flu in total but
sometimes you will get an unexplained
death from the flu in a young healthy
person sometimes it will happen it is a
tiny tiny fraction so isolation stay at
home for older folks of course way more
testing of course fever clinics for sick
people of course close large events of
course masks etc but there is a case
that one could make that we could have
if we were more competently led at the
beginning we could have kept more things
open in a way that would have directly
helped the most vulnerable workers in
the economy while changing the total
risk very little we could have avoided a
lot of economic destruction now that is
me steel Manning a left-wing case
against lockdowns
do I literally believe it 100% of course
not of course not
one example lots of younger people live
with older people so if you want to keep
the young restaurant worker employed but
their grandparents safe and they live
together how do you do it right so it
it doesn't literally work in all cases
but I want to hear your thoughts and the
point that I'm making is left-wing
skepticism of a total and complete stay
at home is OK
the right-wing skepticism and attacks on
the guidelines are ridiculous and
they're wrong and they're laughable
there is a sensible conversation to have
about how it could have been handled
differently and it may be relevant or
when wave 2 happens if we have a break
between wave one and wave two but we've
got to actually think it through and
that's what I'm trying to do with you
right here let me know what you think
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman remember we
have a daily hour podcast that you can
get on iTunes stitcher a google play and
all of your favorite podcast apps make
sure to sign up for it and let me know
your thoughts on Twitter where I am at
Pakman the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Ford
Warwick jr. and Sarah Rodriguez thanks
to both of you for being new members at
david pakman.com slash membership also
want to say thank you to james Mazzoni
james has been a member almost 5 years
if you can believe it and is today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
grab a membership takes under a minute
at david pakman.com slash membership ok
let's go to the phones and see what's on
folks minds today a 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is
of course our number let's start with
our caller from the 9 1 9 area code
who's calling today from 9 1 9 or
actually that may be country code 91 is
that is it cut this country code 91 make
more sense hello
country code yes that is you who's this
India okay very good what's on your mind
yeah so you know mother the black man
who's had their police put his knee on
and you know he was killed on video yes
and you know what what happened was
teachers got fired do you think there's
any way that eventually will will ever
come to a place where these people will
actually be katana for their clients
well you know the I'm actually watching
a couple of documentaries right now
about the difficulty of getting guilty
verdicts for murder and manslaughter for
police officers who kill others in the
line of duty and I mean listen the way
our system works is that you need to be
convinced of guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt and one of the things about our
system is when you are a police officer
and part of your job is to assess
so-called threats and you use deadly
force
if you determine it necessary it is very
easy for a good lawyer to introduce some
doubt and that according to our system
reasonable doubt is all you need for not
for a not guilty verdict and
unfortunately you know even pointing out
this is a trained police officer who
does this for a living
that is the basis for arguing we
probably should doubt that they just
went out and committed murder as we
would call it and so it's a structural
reality of our system and that's what
makes it very difficult to get guilty
verdicts for police killings ya know
there's a video of this kind like in in
the video you can see them crush this
man's head and even I know that he is
going to get fired up yeah and a bunch
of people writing with the same feeling
people writing to me saying that you
know the the the father and son duo who
killed Ahmad are Barry are unlikely to
be found guilty and yeah I mean I don't
think people are wrong in erring on the
side of that being the most likely
outcome it's horrible yeah so the DOJ is
you know they just like decide not to
investigate Linda now this is all Obama
gating how effective you think is that
for these Republicans when they're
talking with by the debating side in it
like you think it's effective like as
effective as Benghazi
no well no I I don't believe it will be
and part of the evidence is that the
discussions of Obama gait are already
starting to fade i I may be wrong but a
couple days ago I checked for Google
searches for it and they're rapidly
diminishing so I think the fact that
you're hearing less about it already is
a sign that they realize it's not going
to have the cachet of Benghazi but I
wouldn't be surprised to see them try to
focus on hunter Biden that may be one
that they're gonna really go all-in on
in the next couple of months we'll see
yeah just like this I can't I don't want
to see so much
information in November sir I can't even
imagine yeah it's gonna be ugly all
right my friend great to hear from you I
think that's the first caller we've ever
gotten from from India I love it let's
go next to our caller from the three one
five area code who is calling today from
three one five uh hey David what would
you like your parents to grow up under
the military government you know
well they imeem so let's so my very good
question my parents did grow up I was
born in Argentina shortly after the end
of the military regime in Argentina my
parents in the 70s you know were young
adults older teenagers and young adults
in the 70s and they were leftists so you
know imagine that you have a coffee shop
and this is a real example from my dad
you have a cafe where the sort of lefty
philosophy Poli Sci students are known
to hang out that becomes a place that is
unsafe because you've got informants of
the military dictatorship
you've got oppression being done by the
military so hey that the cafe is no
longer a safe place for you to go and
just chat with people my parents have
friends who who were disappeared as the
term is certainly you know killed so
they were you know fortunately they were
okay obviously I mean they survived and
and I was born but they were in the
thick of it
they lost friends I think we've had we
have extended family that was killed and
they were right in it I mean they lived
through a military dictatorship the
likes of which is is inconceivable to
most American youth
hello oh boy
all right well listen I I answered not
not clear what happened there but
appreciate the phone call let's go next
to our caller from the 8:02 area code is
a tear over menthe if I remember
correctly yes it is yep
who's this Kayla hey Kayla what's up I
was wondering if you had seen the
Twitter feud between Kyle kolinsky and
jeger about or Jencks basically posted
the lesser of two evils argument with
Biden and then added that you're not
morally superior if you decide for your
own principal reasons or whatever not to
participate in the presidential vote
like and then Kyle said does that mean
I'm morally inferior and Jake said yes I
did I did not see that I did not see
that Kayla I can still comment about the
idea of it but I have I'm gonna I'm
gonna reveal something to you Kayla that
I have kept secret for about five or six
days twitter has become so toxic for me
that ya have not looked at my replies
other than verified replies for five
days I have not I just I'm tweeting and
I will check my verified replies which I
know is like I know it sounds elitist
but I need some way to kind of reduce
the toxicity of Twitter and then I'll
look at the things I'm following I have
not looked just as a test for five days
I've not looked at my general replies
feed emotionally Kayla I am doing so
much better can you imagine that yeah I
don't you really use Twitter that much
either in you Kyle even said that he
hated that like the fact that he got
into a Twitter feud in the first place
but the interesting point behind the
argument is the voter shaming that's
coming from a lot of people on the left
right now who have decided that they're
going to vote for Biden whether or not
they were progressive and
and Jamie shaming people with views like
Kyle's which is you know Biden doesn't
mean his standards you know war criminal
like universal health care these are
principal things and because of that
he's not going to participate like is
shaming them like worth it yeah I don't
think so here's my view unless actual
voter shaming I don't think is worth it
explaining why you think someone's
calculation is wrong I think is
completely legitimate and the problem is
that the line between voter shaming and
explaining why you think someone is
wrong can be blurry sometimes it's not
blurry but an allegation of voter
shaming can be made to shut down a
conversation now I didn't see this feud
between Genk and Kyle both of whom are
friends of mine so you know it's hard
for me to say specifically whether it
was over the line or on this side of the
line but I agree it's most importantly I
don't think voter shaming will work and
that's one reason why I don't that's a
good idea
but explaining to someone listen the
five things you've said about why you're
not going to vote for Biden to me they
seem kind of like BS if you just prefer
Trump say it and then I will respect
your decision much more but concern
trolling which were sometimes seeing
exaggerations of Biden's of the flaws
were sometimes like let's just be honest
and I wish some people would just
straight up say either because I think
he's better or because I think it would
teach the DNC a lesson I prefer Trump
just say it and I'm not saying Kyle
believes that I want to be clear I would
respect the peanut much more if they
just were upfront about that like if you
give me these choices I actually prefer
Trump
cool okay we'd all have anyway like are
they preferring like if you're not
making the choice are you saying these
are for Trump necessarily not
necessarily but so here's here's why I
have been repeating this idea that not
participating isn't neutral
what I mean by that is Trump won and is
the incumbent incumbency comes with huge
power it's tough to remove an incumbent
president so merely not voting you might
say well it's not helping anyone well
when you consider the power of
incumbency opting out
you could argue actually helps the
incumbent that's sort of like one
argument the second argument for why not
voting arguably is beneficial for Trump
is I'm talking specifically to a lot of
the people who say I'm on the Left and
don't like Trump but I'm still not going
to vote those folks are folks who
specifically have said I don't want
Trump to be the president and aren't
voting so they by virtue of not voting
are helping Donald Trump if you have
people who are on the right and choose
not to vote of course they're helping
Biden there's no doubt about that so
when I say not voting isn't neutral and
it's beneficial to Trump it's number one
because I'm speaking to my mostly
progressive audience who I believe
doesn't like Trump and number two
because the power of incumbency does
make a non-vote unbalanced more
beneficial for the incumbent yeah yeah
all right all right Kate
we're in Vermont are you by the way yeah
I am I've met Bernie several times no
but what part of Vermont I'm in Central
Vermont are you from Montpellier
Montpelier oh very nice I stopped
stopped there last time when I was
driving up to to Montreal had a great
sushi lon you don't think of Montpelier
as the place to get sushi but I got some
great sushi there weird I don't know
where to get right well today it might
be a tough day given what's going on
Kayla I really appreciate the phone call
yep thank you all right take care
let's go next to where do we want to go
next there are so many different people
oh you know who I want to go to let's go
to our friend and reqif from Los Angeles
calling from the three two three we
haven't heard from him for and can you
believe that it's been 10 months since
we heard from you
it's been much yeah Wow feels like
distant you I know what's going on hey I
was I was watching your Joe Rogan the
lesson or girl again
yeah I know it was amazing man I love
watching you talk to people like Joe
Rogan uh just really quick yeah I just
think a little uncock Olinsky I totally
I can't watch him anymore
it really upset me that he said that he
won't vote provided did he say did he
say that or did he say unless Biden
comes around on at least a couple of his
five most important issues he said he's
not voting for him he's just not gonna
will provide oh I didn't know that the
latest play heard and I apologize you
know I haven't looked at Twitter replies
for five days as I mentioned the last I
heard was Kyle would vote for him if
Biden conceded or compromised on two of
Kyle's top five issues when I heard him
he said he said blame me for Trump's
next win that's what he said you can
blame me and I'm okay with that
okay so I don't know yeah but um I was
gonna tell you so I just think again
that the left man I'm so worried about
this election the left really needs to
pull it together again
the reason I'm not listening to calculus
you why is it that the left cannot
cannot even with a threat like Trump
who's destroying this country yeah
cannot come together why how come the
Republicans can get behind a man as
immoral as corrupt a thief a con artists
like Trump but we can't get behind
together for someone like Biden yep
I think Biden is not the best but come
on and it just infuriates me and also
the left is so weak at speaking to its
voters I think I said it the last time
ten months ago but why are we not
showing videos of how Trump is like a
dick
Peter how he's just showing the justice
system how he's putting in judges that
are gonna vote his way how he is
obstruct me just I mean why are we not
betting Americans know what and drinkin
when we say when you say why aren't we
showing the videos who is we are you
like are you talking about CNN or a you
talk like who are you talking about I'm
talking about okay I guess the DNC I
guess the people that are trying to get
him elected that are working getting
paid to get him elected why are they not
showing why are they not strong look I
think the left is so weak right now
I had a conversation with my brother
yesterday he was like and we cam so mad
at the Democrats right now but of course
I'm abided and he's very conservative
hardcore Christian conservative but he's
both liberal and I'm like yeah that's
true we're so weak so there's no here's
the main thing I wanted to address that
you mentioned why does the right seem to
unite around their candidate when the
left sometimes does not I think that
this has a lot to do with the left
having more acceleration as tendencies
and more opposition to incremental ISM
whereas the right if they've got a guy
who talks about grabbing by the [ __ ]
has been married three times was
pro-choice up until you know six months
before he ran for president if he says
I'll put people on the court that will
be against abortion that the Heritage
Foundation or whoever suggests to me and
I'll put in the right judges that's what
they cared they'll take it they'll take
this they're like hey we're gonna get
something here we're not going to get
that with Hillary we're certainly not
going to do anything that helps Hillary
get elected let's put Trump in and you
know what now
another trumpet president is not
completely unlikely it's possible that
now you could get another right winger
at some point the left has a larger
portion of its makeup that is people and
I want to be clear I'm not talking about
Kyle now he has said he's not an
acceleration estai want to be clear
about that you have more people on the
Left who they're not missing the forest
for the trees they only care about the
forest so to speak and when they see hey
Biden
gets you pick a number 70% of what
Burton gets you 65 I don't know what the
number is
whereas Trump gets you less than zero
they say we don't care you know maybe we
want to teach the DNC a lesson or I'm
not going to vote you know for a guy who
20 years ago said he would be open to
policies that he you know is certainly
not running on now or whatever the case
so when you have more accelaration ISM
in your political theory you will see
less of a sort of coming together to
eliminate the greater evil or the evil
as I call it and as you call it yeah and
Ricca you're breaking up so I'm gonna
let you go you're coming in all choppy
like you're on a submarine but I'm gonna
let you go I so appreciate hearing from
you
we have enrique marquez a good caller
good caller and rikka from la let's take
a quick break you don't hang up if
you're holding because I will go right
back to the phone it's going to be
incredible the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show welcome back we
are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 let's go to our caller from the 3:04
area code who's calling today from 3 0 4
hi David my name is Chris from West
Virginia how are you today good how are
you I'm doing fine thank you
so I had a question about I I've read an
article about how Mitch McConnell was
actually trying to eliminate the $600
per week that the the people on
unemployment are receiving extra yeah so
people know what that is unemployment is
a state program different states have
different levels of unemployment
benefits because of coronavirus the
federal government is enhancing
unemployment by up to $600 a week in
addition to what you get from the state
that that's what Chris is talking about
good right so what do you personally
believe his motivation is behind that
why why would he do that ok so it's
essentially a way to force States to
have to reopen and if you have more and
more people who are lacking the money
they need to make ends meet you are
going to create a situation where they
are more likely to take the risks
associated with going back to work I
mean it's it's really as simple as that
we could say more about it we could say
more about I mean listen I think it's
short-sighted because obviously in the
short term it might get more businesses
reopened if in the long term it spreads
infection it's going to lead to more and
subsequent closures but that is what
seems to be at
root of it yeah I believe that if it
keeps going on like this that a lot of
people are going to die yeah we're gonna
have to be forced to read you know to
close again and I just don't I just
don't understand how they could how they
could really live with themselves after
doing that so I agree with you now if
there's another reason so I'm I think
that's the main reason but if there's
another reason why Mitch McConnell is
doing it I mean listen Mitch McConnell
is generally speaking a skeptical of a
lot of social welfare programs in
general so I think any opportunity
Republicans have to cut social welfare
they will do it but at least with regard
to the virus that's that's what what I
think is going on for states to open by
cutting unemployment benefits okay well
that actually makes a little more sense
now I appreciate your time David thank
you very much all right Chris from West
Virginia very much appreciate the phone
call let's go next to our caller from
the 909 area code who's calling today
from nine zero nine I David my name is
Jane hey Shane what's up I was calling
to ask you about drummers I want to know
who your favorite drummers are oh my
goodness there's so many I mean you know
it depends on the genre you know you've
got somebody like the great late John
Bonham from the 70s rock era Steve Gadd
is a tremendous drummer Vinnie Colaiuta
you there's just so many so many
drummers you know in the sort of Latin
space TD Ortiz is fantastic it's it runs
the gamut there's just so many different
great drummers out there Carter Beauford
you know from the sort of Dave Matthews
genre whatever that genre is it's a it's
an almost limitless list we yeah nice
choice is already really cool that's
that's my only question ok I appreciate
you answering it and I appreciate your
book recommendations as well all right
thank you so much very much appreciate
the phone call thank you yeah all right
take care let's see let's check in with
our caller from country code 44 country
code 44 who's this where you're calling
from
hello yeah that's you yeah i'm i'm a
student in edinburgh now just in the
middle of a project but I guess want to
call in I'm a first-time caller
I I've really been interested in
American politics for so long now and to
be honest with you I used to look down
on people that didn't partake in
elections myself but with all that's
happened in this Democratic primary and
and stuff the people I look down on now
is the people has actually bothered to
take part in these these elections mmm
you know I never understood why people
didn't vote but now I do you know Bernie
Sanders what what the DNC did to him in
terms of the way they reorganized
themselves you know to reorient around
Biden the way all the candidates have
dropped out a organized nature of of
this was really just got to me and you
know I just don't understand how people
can look at Biden and think you know
yeah I mean there's no doubt that Biden
is better than Trump no W is doubting
that for one second but what happens
after you know a Biden presidency you
know are we just going to assume that
Biden is to set up to you know a better
future for America to be honest with you
the way American history suggests right
after Biden there's just going to be
another trumpet you know I don't get it
I mean I don't agree I don't I don't
believe that that's at all a guarantee I
think about it I think about it this way
imagine you know a large cruise ship and
you have one place you want it to go and
Republicans have a different place that
that they wanted to go for me the
perfect analogy which is an
incrementalist analogy rather than an
acceleration isten allergy is the
earlier you turn towards your
destination the less erratic your future
turns need to be
and we've all seen these examples of you
know of a small change in the angle at
which you leave Boston could get you to
Scotland or it could get you to Morocco
and so my view is not one where every
election needs to be assessed as what is
the setup for the subsequent election
and what is it likely to lead to what I
know is another four years of Trump
steering the ship gets us much further
than where four years of Biden gets us
in either case at the end of the next
four years we're not going to be where
we want to be but we will be closer with
Joe Biden and for me it's that simple so
I think we just have a fundamental
disagreements of the principle here yeah
but um I I look at you know the Obama
campaign for instance interim he ran as
a poppy face basically a populist in
2008 for all intensive purposes you know
it's especially when you juxtapose him
against somebody like you know Clinton
and I agree so I agree that you know
Clinton Obama ran on a populist ish sort
of campaign but really Obama I think ran
on a you know sort of pragmatic
center-left
you know more open to progressive ideas
than someone like Clinton but I don't
know that I would primarily characterize
Obama's campaign as populist yeah but
you know um what I'm trying to say is
when you look at the last three
elections yeah and you looked at you
know that the sort of people that did
the people that lost the last three
elections you know John McCain Mitt
Romney Clinton you know these are
establishment candidates you know these
are people that you know have a vote
have made a name for themselves in
politics for such a long time before
they decide to run and you look at Obama
and Trump you know relatively speaking
they they were nobody's can argue with
that quite clear at this point that the
American keep
they want something new they don't want
more of the same and my worry is that
Biden who you know people look at Biden
and go well I would rather give trumpet
another full year as ridiculous that may
seem some people may actually say that
so here's here's my father he's my
understand I understand what you're
saying here's why I disagree with it
number one Donald Trump is such a
different political animal than anything
we've had before and remember Obama was
a was a new US senator but he was a u.s.
senator he was not you know some
privileged real estate dude from from
New York City so so Trump is in a league
of his own I believe that listen we'll
see what happens in November I believe
that Joe Biden has a reasonable shot at
winning we don't know what will happen
because Donald Trump has been so
outrageous that people are looking for a
return to something more familiar now
that's not a defensive centrist politics
and I hope that Joe Biden if he wins you
know we have to do everything we can to
pull him to the left in every
opportunity but I actually think that
the circumstances are so unique that
going back to something that feels more
normal is exactly what a lot of people
want yeah and just just to add because I
kept hope hope to - well I don't believe
in God but hope to whatever that's yeah
come 20/20 21 the Senate hopefully I
don't know how you see that happening
but the Senate somehow just finds a way
to become blue hopefully yeah yeah I've
done a bunch of analyses on that so I
won't go over the details but it's
certainly it's possible it's yeah he'll
battle but it's but it's possible listen
I really appreciate the call from
Scotland yeah
thank you thank you very much all right
take care hope to hear from you again
let's see who else I can pick up on here
how about let's go to the 907 area code
if indeed that is someone in New York
City would love to hear what is going on
there it's me yes it is hi how are you
good how are you who's this this is
avery
great what's going on
um oh good I have a couple of questions
okay um I'm a software engineer and I'm
very unsure how this entire election
will proceed it it seems it seems that
the American people aren't very
trustworthy when it comes to elect you
know online elections and I'm unsure how
voting turnouts will be hold on long
who's learning who's voting online
I mean online voting yeah where what
states are doing online voting Trenton
I don't know I don't know what you're
going to be doing online voting but this
is my word but I think any word about
that the question is in person versus
vote-by-mail mm-hmm mmhmm yeah oh okay I
see
yeah okay so it's going to be voting by
mail well hopefully yeah I mean that's
the idea
all right the states will transfer to
voting by mail okay all right and it's
not even really a transfer I mean in in
reality so this is an important
distinction what we're really talking
about is just expanding the absentee
ballot systems that are already there
like every state already has an absentee
ballot system some states like Oregon
have been exclusively vote by mail since
the 90s so we're not really talking
about creating any new systems we're
just scaling up the existing vote by
mail systems that are there ah all right
okay with something that I've been that
have been quite worried about yeah but I
haven't quite done enough research in so
thanks for thanks for that clarification
but I also have another another question
that has been quite bothering me of late
I'm not particularly left-wing or
right-wing for that matter I'm more a
more centrist and I don't see and I
don't understand why people are so anti
Trump
I've you know i sat here on on the phone
for 20 minutes listening to
whatever his name was because names of
Enrique and he was calling Trump a thief
and a criminal evil I see people in your
comments um you know I heard I just read
one like it was an hour ago that Trump
raised a thirteen-year-old girl
these these are a outrageous claims well
hold on let's let's take a step back
let's address a couple different things
so first of all Trump was accused of
raping a thirteen-year-old girl she
ultimately you know dropped the suit
because it appears that there was huge
huge pressure but that that's that that
is the allegation to say that it's true
you know we don't have proof of that I
wouldn't look at YouTube comments
necessarily but listen the reason Trump
is so bad is he is incompetent in a way
that is lethal it is lethal competence
100 100 percent he that's very pathetic
Bendi increase the deficit spending
without cutting without cutting the
budget yeah but that doesn't make him
that doesn't make them evil or that's
that's not that that is not political
football they all do that but the the
lethal incompetence the corruption the
doing the opposite of everything he
promised the hypocrisy double standards
I think with this is where I'm not I'm
not quite following okay I understand I
understand all from some economics
perspective I see and I understand what
he's doing wrong okay from a leadership
point of view I see how he's incompetent
okay it runs his mouth and how it could
be dangerous especially when handling
people like the the president of China
and the president of North Korea yeah I
see all of this okay and um I'm I'm
particularly not so I'm not a big fan of
Trump for that reason but from the left
I see a big you know a big character
attack against Trump sure he has a big
mouth and whatnot but um okay but hold
on every
so you're saying that Trump is terrible
on economics and his leadership has been
a failure but you're not sure why the
left dislikes him so much I mean like
that's why you know and sir you know to
the extent that you don't like the tone
of the left it's you know it if that's
really what we're saying you don't like
the way that some of the left criticizes
him okay I mean I don't know it doesn't
seem like a huge deal it's you know if
we're gonna talk about tone we've got to
look at Trump but you said it yourself
he's bad on economics and he's a failed
leader I wouldn't say he's a sales
leader per se he didn't do things that
for Mike for my um his foreign policy is
okay
from my perspective he's not he's most
certainly not the most confident man I
would vote for but I don't I don't quite
I don't quite understand why there's
such a harsh reaction from the left I
know it sounds every like I see all
north of um you don't like Trump but you
you don't like Trump and you you're not
exactly on the same page with the left
as to the degree to which you don't like
him is that sort of what you're saying
well yes well that that's one thing but
I mean I don't quite understand why it's
so hard
I see the left always looking for angles
to attack Trump on on you know with
always a whole Russia gate conspiracy
here that lasted for years years will be
a constant one for years yeah yeah yeah
that's true but this whole scandal just
went for years and then he plopped on
its head and I kept hearing on the news
Russia Russia Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia Russia well now it sounds
like a pretty us about the news not so
much about the left right I mean I'm
having trouble it's weird I'm having
trouble following what your argument is
I guess you just don't think the less
you guys although certainly have an
argument I'm trying to I'm trying to ask
you why why is there this wise of this
particular harsh
view of Trump and his constant attack
and trying to find the angles on them um
you know finding angles it's you don't
really need to go finding angles you're
talking about a guy who is in completely
over his head doesn't listen to experts
thinks he knows more than everybody
seems emotionally unstable doesn't
understand economics doesn't understand
public policy doesn't understand foreign
policy doesn't understand geopolitics
can't take responsibility for a single a
single mistake and is regularly making
errors that lead to people dying as we
are seeing with coronavirus I don't know
what you know if you just don't see that
as warranting people on the left being
upset then we probably just have
different values in the end well I don't
know I don't see I hear oh it's all your
latest video where Trump accused
perfectly this video of yours on your
channel or Trump accused um I think it
was a report no it wasn't a reporter a
TV show host of accuse them of murder
yes and then and then um you didn't say
anything anything particularly you
didn't lay you know the coronavirus dips
on his feet but I saw many you know as
how many people who did yeah from is not
responsible is not responsible for
100,000 deaths but just one week earlier
of saying we've got to shut things down
could have saved 30,000 people two weeks
earlier could have saved 50 so certainly
Trump is not responsible for coronavirus
but his inaction is certainly tied to
some of the deaths listen my friend I
got a run but I I guess I understand you
just you're not you don't see why the
left dislikes Trump so much and and
that's fine it sounds like we have we
have sort of different ways of
evaluating and that's that's okay but
I'm just trying to tell you why many on
the Left do see this as a lethally
incompass
man that's all the time I have for calls
today sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take calls again
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on the support of our viewers and
listeners and one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month or as
much as you want at patreon.com slash
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
all right we've got some very thick and
needy audience questions today some of
which are coming right at me and I love
it let's get to the first one David
aren't you a hypocrite for criticizing
our financial system and then making
money from it
investing in stocks and bonds and I'm
sure paying as little in taxes as you
are legally allowed to uh no no I am NOT
a hypocrite listen that this has been
explored in so many different ways why
doesn't Bernie just pay more taxes and
send checks to the IRS
why does noam chomsky one of the
greatest critics of some of the
inequalities in our economic system have
a trust or some other mechanism I
believe it is so he can transfer his
mutual funds which include ownership of
oil companies to his kids while paying
as little tax as possible or whatever
the case may be we've really got to
disaggregate this stuff and and think
through in a bit a more critical way
what we're really asking here let's take
first let's take some examples first if
you believe taxes should be higher why
don't you just send in more money that's
not policy okay that's not policy the
the idea that just the people who
believe taxes should be higher sending
in more money is how you resolve a
problem with government tax revenue or
fairness or whatever the case may be is
a joke and in fact if everybody isn't do
it doing it there is really no reason
why one person would do it because it
wouldn't make a difference and this is
why a lot of these things need to be
done collectively the groups that like
to say just leave this stuff to charity
we don't need social safety nets we can
just leave it to charity well maybe but
that's not policy maybe people are more
generous versus less generous one year
to the next
you can't fix problems in society
predictably with that policy so you know
here in Massachusetts you have I think
there's this option you have to pay a
higher income tax rate I think the
income tax rate here is five point oh
five percent and you can pay like five
point eight if you
I always put no and in fact I actually
don't even think the state income tax
needs to be higher I think where we need
more and higher tax brackets or
federally but that's a completely
different question along the same lines
I am a person that exists in society I
believe there are many problems with our
economic system but does that mean that
what I need to do is put my money under
a mattress where its purchasing power is
diminished by inflation every single
year what would that serve other than to
unnecessarily impoverish myself by
keeping money under a mattress I believe
for example that capital gains should be
taxed at or as ordinary income does that
mean that when I file my taxes and I
only pay you know 15% on capital gains
I'm gonna say hey you know what let me
just send the IRS more money no that's
not policy there is no hypocrisy as long
as you are not you know advocating for
non-violence and being a violent person
right I mean that we can find these
types of hippocrates that would be
different but recognizing that we exist
in a certain financial system we are
people we have a desire for wellbeing
and whatever else and we are going to
play by the rules that are there while
explaining that at a societal level we
would be better off if the rules were
changed is not hypocritical and again
the example of Noam Chomsky having a
trust - I forget the exact response he
had when he was called out on some
reporter said you know you talk about
inheritance taxes and this and that but
you invest in mutual funds that hold
pieces of oil companies and also have a
trust to give money to your kids
Chomsky's reaction was what I should I
should be a popper or I don't remember
exactly what the response was but the
point is these are not societal
questions that the individual is making
and of course you should live your
values and if you individually say for
me I would rather lose my money then
have a retirement possibility that
include zoning mutual funds than do it
then go ahead and do it but to say
anybody who thinks oil companies are bad
but owns mutual funds is somehow a bad
person come on guys who even has time to
go around making those arguments let's
just work on improving the systems we
have and fixing the problems that we
have rather than trying to find these
gotcha questions of people who you know
have been may have made very clear what
their values are and how they believe
society should be organized David Donald
Trump is increasingly talking about
giving businesses immunity from
coronavirus related lawsuits does this
make sense or should employees always be
able to sue sue and seek damages from
their employer if they were to catch
coronavirus as a result of being back at
work listen this is really a complicated
issue from a practicum a logistical
sense from a legal sense where you have
to understand well what is the current
liability that employers have is
catching coronavirus the same as an
unsafe warehouse where you get run over
by a forklift because the forklift
didn't make the beeping noise and have
the red light that it's supposed to have
and steel toed shoes weren't require
right these are these are very different
questions when it comes to something
like coronavirus if you go to work and
you catch coronavirus and everybody was
behaving safely and the employer has
opened in accordance with CDC guidelines
foreign state guidelines for okay
employees need masks and the employees
had masks there should be X number of
sanitation's they if all the rules are
being adhered to and people catch
coronavirus it's very difficult to say
that the employer should be liable for
that particularly when the contagion may
have happened because of some random
customer or who knows it's a very
difficult legal question but should
there be some blanket immunity for
employers of course
of course not we have an infrastructure
for determining when an employer is or
is not liable for something that happens
to an employee or to a customer on the
premises it is very robust legislation
it is very established there is no
shortage of cases of all kinds about
employers who failed to protect
employees and customers or who were sued
but it was determined they actually did
take the proper precautions the danger
here is that for political reasons and
for the purposes of furthering what has
become a culture war over coronavirus
Donald Trump is seeking to give blanket
immunity for anything coronavirus
related that happens in their place of
business when they reopen and what this
is really about is employers who are not
following the guidelines that Trump
wants to see have immunity so that they
will just open up even when it is not
yet safe to do so on the basis of the
guidelines that have been put in place
this is about Trump wanting to give a
carte blanche sort of situation to
employers that want to reopen and even
though the state says you need masks
they don't want their employees to wear
masks and in some cases may even tell
their employees no masks whatsoever so
for me the last thing we need is any
blanket immunity for employers but I am
sensitive to the reality that your
employer can be doing the right thing
and you might get coronavirus versus
your employer might not be doing the
right thing those are the situations
that need to be adjudicated listen
here's the reality if you're an
essential worker at a grocery store and
you continue working we know that the
longer you are in places where the virus
is circulating your odds of contracting
it go way way up spending 15 minutes
with a mask on at Trader Joe's even if
there are people in there with the virus
is not hugely likely to end up with you
getting the virus spending eight hours a
day five or six days a week there even
with a mask dramatically still sees an
increase in the chance that you get it
does that mean the
lawyer is acting inappropriately and
should be sued no not necessarily what I
do think is that essential workers
should be compensated additionally for
the fact that they are essential and are
often some of the least well-paid people
that's a battle I'll have all day long
but if employers really are being safe
we have a system that would adjudicate
that and would say this lawsuit has no
merit the employer did the right thing
everybody did the right thing we have a
contagious situation if grocery stores
should have been closed that's a bigger
governmental call that should have been
made but we don't need any special
dispensation as the case may be from
Donald Trump or the federal government
to shield a priori employers because
employers may take advantage of that and
some will take advantage of it to have
deliberately unsafe conditions that they
believe are better for them in the short
and maybe medium term you could say
listen over the long term if all your
employees get sick and a bunch of them
die it's bad for PR you're not going to
have employees okay
there are lots of industries that have
such turnover as it is that they
regularly have a stable of applicants
and they can bring people in quickly and
train them relatively quickly for
relatively unskilled labor many
businesses would not really be concerned
about that
so no blanket immunity we have a system
that can determine is this a valid claim
or is this what we would call a
frivolous claim they don't need any
special bailout it's part of the culture
war it's part of this haphazard desire
to open the economy fully immediately
regardless of the what the repercussions
are in my experience any blanket
immunities for corporations from future
lawsuits are bad news
I am open to the idea that sometimes
they are okay I looked today for
examples couldn't find any couldn't find
any if you have an example absolutely
let me know we have a great bonus show
for you today I hope you will be there
get a membership at join pakman.com to
get instant access and remember you can
sign up for free for the daily audio
podcast of the show a lot of people
don't know there's a daily hour-long
podcast it's on iTunes it's on stitcher
you can find
a feed link on our website it's
available make sure you're signed up for
that Pat's got the bonus show today I'll
be back on Monday
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video